Hallö - Da kam so ein Fussel raus als ich so gemacht hab!
Wir sind heute wieder sehr seriös unterwegs!
Hallöchen ihr Lieben! Wir machen heute Gözleme.
Die Idee kam eigentlich so im letzten Pide Rezept von mir, da hat der Hamza in den Raum geworfen: "Och, mach doch mal Gözleme!"
Und euch hat die Idee so gut gefallen, dass wir das jetzt heute machen.
Gözleme sind türkische Teigtaschen, die sind sehr dünn, fein,
befüllt mit entweder Hackfleisch-, Kartoffel- oder Schafskäsefüllung.
Ich hab auf Instagram gefragt, was ihr sehen möchtet und die Mehrheit lag bei Kartoffel
und bei der Schafskäse-Spinatfüllung, und das machen wir heute auch.
Der Teig geht ganz schnell, besteht aus nur wenigen Zutaten und braucht auch keine Hefe.
Ich mache das jetzt mit den Händen.
Die ganz genauen Mengenangaben stehen wie immer unten in der Videobeschreibung, falls ihr neu seid und euch jetzt wundert.
Und ich nehme mir jetzt von meinem Mehl - Das ist diesmal übrigens Typ 550, nicht 405 -
Ihr müsst euch vorstellen: Mehl Typ 405 ist so das Standardmehl
und Typ 550 ist nochmal ein bisschen weniger verarbeitet und hat nochmal andere Eigenschaften.
Ihr dürft in dem Rezept aber auch das ganz normale Mehl Typ 405 verwenden falls ihr das andere gerade nicht da habt.
Ich mach's immer so, dass ich mir so ungefähr 15g schon mal wegnehme von der Gesamtmasse.
Gebe das hier rein und dann fange ich an, die anderen Zutaten mit dazu zu geben.
Das ist einmal Wasser (da nehme ich gerne warmes damit es sich besser verbindet),
Olivenöl, Salz und Zucker.
Und dann fange ich an, zu kneten und gebe immer wieder etwas mehr vom Mehl dazu.
So, jetzt habe ich ca. 3-4min auf der Arbeitsfläche geknetet,
immer wieder ein bisschen Mehl dazugegeben aber alles habe ich auch nicht gebraucht.
Daher macht das lieber so als wenn ihr zu viel Mehl drin habt und der Teig dann zu trocken wird.
Der sollte gerade so nicht mehr kleben und schön elastisch sein.
Der muss jetzt aber noch mal ein bisschen entspannen.
Daher rolle ich ihn jetzt zu einer Kugel, so ganz grob
und gebe das in meine Schüssel zurück, fette die aber vorher ein.
Auch die Oberfläche ein bisschen fetten, abdecken und dann 45min lang entspannen lassen.
Der wird jetzt nicht noch mal richtig aufgehen - wir haben ja auch keine Hefe drin,
aber wir brauchen das für die Konsistenz später.
So, die Ruhzeit nutze ich jetzt aus und mache die 2 Füllungen fertig.
Wir starten jetzt einfach mal mit der Feta-Spinat-Füllung.
Dafür habe ich die Zwiebeln schon mal fein gehackt, die habe ich jetzt für beide Füllungen schon mal gehackt.
Ich gebe gleich die Hälfte in meine beschichtete Pfanne, gebe da ein bisschen Olivenöl mit rein
und dann dünsten wir das auf mittlerer Stufe an und geben anschließend Spinat mit dazu.
Da könnt ihr frischen nehmen, ich nehme jetzt einfach Tiefkühlspinat.
Und dann lassen wir das so lange garen, bis die Flüssigkeit verdampft
damit dann auch später im Gözleme nicht so viel Flüssigkeit austritt vom Spinat.
Den Fetakäse dann einfach dazubröseln - den Herd habe ich jetzt schon ausgeschaltet -
und das Ganze miteinander vermischen. Jetzt fehlen nur noch 3 Gewürze.
Ich finde immer bei der Füllung: Es müssen keine 1000 Gewürze da rein weil der Eigengeschmack ist schon super lecker.
Also nehmen wir nur Salz, Pfeffer und Pul Biber.
Das sind quasi türkische Paprikaflocken, die sind ein bisschen scharf.
Jetzt machen wir die Kartoffelfüllung und die geht auch richtig schnell.
Und die ist mein persönlicher Favorit, ich liebe einfach diese Kartoffelfüllung
und ich muss sagen: Ich snacke die auch manchmal einfach so!
Ich gebe jetzt hier einfach noch mal Olivenöl in meinen beschichteten Topf
und dünste darin bei mittlerer Geschwindigkeit - Geschwindigkeit!
Bei mittlerer Temperatur.
Und da geben wir jetzt die restlichen Zwiebeln dazu und dünsten die so ungefähr 2min lang schön glasig
und danach gebe ich auch schon Paprikamark dazu.
So, die gar gekochten Kartoffeln habe ich jetzt direkt mit rein gegeben und einfach zerstampft.
Da müsst ihr auch gar nicht so ordentlich sein, das darf ruhig noch ein bisschen stückig sein.
Den Herd habe ich auch schon ausgeschaltet, Hitze brauchen wir jetzt nicht mehr.
Und jetzt würze ich auch wieder mit Salz, Pfeffer und Pul Biber.
Ihr dürft auch noch wenn ihr mögt ein bisschen Muskatnuss dazugeben, das passt immer ganz gut zu Kartoffeln.
Und was bei mir nicht fehlen darf, ist dann noch Petersilie, die ich fein gehackt habe.
Die Kartoffelfüllung ist auch fertig, das gebe ich jetzt kurz an die Seite.
Meine - meine Zeit ist abgelaufen wollte ich schon fast sagen!
Die Ruhzeit ist jetzt durch, der Teig hat sich entspannt.
Wie von Anfang an schon gesagt ist er nicht hochgegangen, das brauchen wir auch bei dem Rezept nicht.
Also nehme ich ihn jetzt raus und teile ihn in 10 gleichmäßig große Teile,
die ich dann noch mal zu Kugeln rolle und dann nehme ich mir halt vor,
jeden einzelnen Teigling richtig schön dünn auszurollen.
So, den Teig habe ich jetzt richtig hauchfein ausgerollt, man kann richtig durchgucken!
So, die Gözleme habe ich jetzt mit den Händen noch so ein bisschen flach gedrückt, das ist wirklich so ein flaches Gebäck.
Es ist sehr lecker, vor allem freut man sich immer auf die Füllung.
Und die werden jetzt in der fettfreien beschichteten Pfanne ausgebacken.
Eine gute Beschichtung sollte sie haben.
Meine Pfannen haben alle eine PEEK-Beschichtung, außerdem sind die Pfannen kratzfest.
Ich werde sie euch in die Infobox verlinken.
Und jetzt einfach reinlegen und von beiden Seiten ausbacken.
Gebt den Gözleme auf jeden Fall Zeit in der Pfanne.
Also so von jeder Seite mindestens 3min würde ich sagen aber ihr seht's auch anhand der Farbe.
Und da der Teig so dünn ist, braucht ihr euch keine Gedanken darüber machen, ob er denn durch ist oder nicht.
Und wir machen jetzt auch einen entscheidenden Schritt, super wichtig:
Ein Stück Butter und dann einfach die warmen Gözleme damit benetzen/bestreichen.
Und genießt das auf jeden Fall noch warm!
Das ist einfach Perfektion weil der Teig wirklich hauchdünn ist, wie Zeitungspapier!
Wenn nicht sogar noch dünner!
Und ich kann jetzt leider nicht vor der Kamera probieren
weil wir noch fasten und die Sonne noch nicht untergegangen ist aber wir holen das auf Instagram nach!
Und die schmecken einfach richtig lecker, probiert sie unbedingt aus!
Und folgt uns auf Instagram wenn ihr das nicht schon längst tut,
ich schreibe euch Hamza's und meinen Account hier unten in die Infobox.
Und ansonsten wünsche ich euch ganz viel Spaß beim Nachmachen.
Genießt sie einfach schön warm, ihr könnt sie aber auch am nächsten Tag noch aufwärmen
und ansonsten habt noch einen wunderschönen Tag!
Bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen, Tschüss!
[Hamza] Weißt du, warum ich heute nicht geredet habe?
[Kiki] Ja, du warst echt still heute!
[Hamza] Ich hab miesen Mundgeruch!
[Kiki] *lacht*